can we uh
walk back to the the the mathematical
olympia yes what's the scoring and
format like
uh and also what does it take to win so
the way it works is that each of the six
students
do the problems and there are six
problems all the problems are equally
weighted so each one's worth seven
points that means that your maximum
score is six problems times seven points
which is the nice number of 42
and now the way that they're scored by
the way is
there's partial credit so the question
is asking you explain why
this weird fact is true okay if you
explain why you get seven points if you
make minor mistake maybe you get six
points
but if you don't succeed in explaining
why but you explain
some other true fact
which is along the way of proving it
then you get partial credit and and
actually now this is tricky because
how do you score such a thing it's not
like it was the answer was
72 and you wrote 71 and it's close right
the answer is 72 and you wrote 36
oh but that's pretty close because you
were you know you that maybe you're just
off
by the way they're not numerical anyway
but i'm just giving some numerical
analog
to the way the scoring might work they
are all essays
and that's where i guess i have some
role as well as some other people who
help me in the us delegation
for coaches we actually debate
with the country which is organizing it
the country which is organizing the
olympiad brings about
50 people to help judge the written
solutions
and you you schedule these half-hour
appointments
where the delegation from one country
sits down at the table like this
the opposite side is two or three people
from the host country
and they're just looking over these exam
papers saying
well how many points is this worth based
on some rubric that has been designed
and this is a negotiation process where
we're not
we're not trying to bargain and get the
best score we can in fact sometimes we
go to this table and we will say
we think we want less than what you gave
us this is how this is how our
these are our principles if you give us
too much we say no you gave us too much
we do that however the reason why this
is an interesting process is because if
you can imagine every country which is
participating has its own language
and so if you're trying to grade the
mongolian scripts and they're written in
mongolia don't read mongolian which
most people don't then the the coaches
are
explaining to you this is what the
student has written
it's actually quite an interesting
process it's almost like um
like a jury yeah you have you have uh
in the american legal system you have a
jury that where they're deliberating
but unlike a jury there's the members of
the jury
speak in different languages sometimes
that's fascinating
but uh i mean it's hard to know what to
do
because it's probably really really
competitive
but your sense is that ultimately people
like how do you prevent manipulation
here
right well we just hope that it's not
happening
so so we write in english therefore
everything that the us
does everyone can look at so it's a it's
very hard for us very hard to manipulate
it
we don't manipulate we only hope that
other people aren't
but at the same time as you see our
philosophy was we want to use this as a
way to develop general talent
and although we do this for the six
people who go to the international math
olympiad
we really want that everyone at any
touch at any stage of this process
gets some skills that can help to
contribute more later
you